hello everybody I guess that's my
entrance music look at this look look
look look lord thank you for coming
everybody thank you very very much so
nice to see you so nice to see you a big
movie like this calls for a grand affair
like this for a press conference and
that's why I guess I'm here in my grand
master of ceremonies colors and costume
because I'm going to facilitate this
hour-long conference in which I hope
you'll all leave deeply satiated because
they're all here believe it or not and
so without further ado what the heck is
behind our curtain done part of wow wow
look at that I get look at all of so
here's here's the way that is going to
go this is a you've seen this for many
game shows I'm going to do this they
call this you know what they call this I
just learned it today this is the hopper
I'm gonna take a ping pong ball and on
these balls are people's names and if
you have questions for a question for
one of those people I will call on you
that's when to raise your hand or there
may be a category that will suggest one
of the people up here for which you may
have a question from which I'm then
going to choose you get the idea
okay watch and see if this if this Falls
of how quickly this falls apart let's
see I'm now going tonight I keep it like
this oh my gosh my gosh Robert Downey
jr. does anybody have a question for
Robert Downey jr. yes yes sir I saw your
your hand go up first yes are you gonna
be an Avengers for Kevin wait hold on a
second he's nodding his head but let me
see what he whispers in my ear yes we
already found it which means I guess I'm
you never know I I gotta see in the
screening more if I die tomorrow I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be confused
we'll see excellent question
excellent answer okay I'm doing it blind
I'm not looking
this says oh oh this says you could this
is a category so you can ask anybody a
question who is from what kind
I'm also a high school math teacher in
Los Angeles and my question is for
Leticia hello in my lessons to keep my
students engaged and I was wondering how
you see your role as a really powerful
and fun woman on screen in math and
science as inspiring kids and teens to
pursue STEM fields Wow I think you kind
of covered it yeah I'm it's something
that's super new to me and to play this
character and to have a character who's
just interested in all of these amazing
subject matters I wish I had a Sheree on
TV or in the movies that I could see
when I was growing up and I would have
stayed at my maths classes a little bit
longer
but I'm really happy that the film and
this character Sheree has allowed young
kids to feel like learning is cool and
that they can contribute in to the to
the world with you know science and
maths and technology and engineering and
also young women as well getting pulled
into that whole movement of feeling like
it's not just a thing for the guys it's
also for the for the young women too
young men young women old women you know
anyone to just get get into and and
contribute positively so to have that
and for you to use it in your classroom
and for many other people to use it to
I'm super grateful and I just hope it
continues and yeah it's positive and
it's good in it it's it's a good thing
so thank you
very beautiful question very beautiful
answer Oh Don Cheadle Don Cheadle hi
Mark Hughes with Forbes and I'm
wondering on in terms of each
character's arc being served in infinity
war your character obviously had a
somewhat of a tribe to guard the last
time we saw in civil war can you talk
about thanks vision can you talk about a
little bit about preparing for infinity
war and carrying over that it's
something that you know all the
characters have tragedies and things in
their life but your character is dealing
with something very immediate to have to
overcome on top of everything else
that's being faced here well what I
think is really great about having
something like this in a way to anchor a
lot of the other things that are
happening in the story and getting to
continue it forward through through both
of the films is that you know we get to
we always get to have these sort of down
notes in a good way I think there's
always a lot of eye candy and very
dramatic things happening and big
spectacular fights and really amazing
things that we see on screen and then it
comes down to these characters in their
interpersonal situations with one
another and their personal journeys that
they have and where it comes to Rhodey
I'm glad that this is something that's
carried through and that is you know
wasn't just dropped it's a line that is
actually goes through both of the films
and and comes into play in a very
important way I won't give it away but
it's something that factors in all the
way through so it's nice to have
something that's cohesive and continues
and keeps keeps me grounded and keeps
the character grounded hey so you can
ask a question if you have a question
for somebody who wears a cape I have a
question for Chris Hemsworth because I'm
a big Thor fan what scene did you find
most challenging to film for this movie
and why was it because of the people in
it was it because of the
rector was it you know just anything
like that
so very difficult because of the
directors and the people in itself film
it's an awful experience myself Jeff and
Tom were going back to our own movies
from now on the most difficult the first
day was what you've seen on the Bund the
trailers it was for meeting the
Guardians and it felt like kind of first
day at school for me you know because
they all knew each other and I didn't I
was a new kid and they'd all been
shooting and I had and add some weird
sort of nervous butterflies floating
around my body and but it was but I
squeezed them out of me you know Chris
Chris Pratt gave me a big hug and all
the butterflies flew into my ears and we
had this whole film for me was I felt
like a fan and meeting a lot of these
people in the characters that I'd
watched on screen and admired and so to
be on screen with him as Thor but as
Chris also I was pretty damn exciting
[Music]
Kevin Feige what if there's anything you
used to sort of ground these movies in
there in their origins beyond just the
characters and the stories anything
visually anything fanatically that
you've used to sort of pull all this
together well it's you will not be
surprised to hear it's the comics it's
the it's the comics that we look at
usually when there is just the notion of
let's do an Iron Man movie or let's have
the audacity to try to do a version of
the Infinity Gauntlet it starts with
those comics and us beginning to rip
pages out or rip copies of pages out put
them on the walls and start to be
inspired and in every single movie we've
made up to an especially infinity war
there are direct images storylines
rarely but sometimes actual lines of
dialogue that come from those pages that
we've that we've put up around our
development room for inspiration and
with and with infinity war in particular
when there were so many characters and
so many threads of storylines from so
many movies that we could have pulled
from or could have used as inspiration
and we did we kept going back to and I
think we've released
behind-the-scene videos and things and
you can see the giant omnibus of the
Infinity Gauntlet there with all sorts
of dog-eared pages and and post-its in
there from moments and after everybody
sees the movie we can talk more
specifically about what those moments
were most of them were surrounding mr.
Berlin's Thanos portrayal that came
directly from Jim starlings work there
so it is always a guide point it's a
North Star for us as we lead these giant
productions into reality or right from
those books and where it all started
you're to ask a question or volunteer to
be considered for being called on for a
question if you if you are green this is
for soy selenium because from what we
heard stories told from the Fanus point
of view part of it and obviously I
wanted to know how that dimension sort
of pushed your portrayal of Gomorrah for
because obviously it's a sort of very
emotional psychological journey for her
so if you could talk about that well
echoing what Don was saying that
besides you know these kinds of movies
carrying so much action and
entertainment and visual effects that
really cater to to all of our sentences
and we wouldn't we wouldn't be what we
are I think in the Marvel Universe if it
wasn't for those emotional beats that
all of these interrelationships carry
and and that obviously in this and you
know that and that thread involves a
relationship between parent and child
and and I will speak on behalf of also
carrying Dylan's character nebula we had
so much fun with with the arc that the
Russo brothers and obviously Kevin Fahey
you know spearheading this with the
relationship that these daughters have
with their father because they finally
get an opportunity to sort of address
what it what it was like to to have a
dad that's so complicated
so it was it was fantastic it was great
oh my gosh
so nobody first saw this I think this
may be well I don't know this is Zoe
Saldana so my question is you kind of we
got to see you first and then you get to
see everybody as Black Panther has
happen people of color joining and these
superhero roles and you were just so
trend-setting and so ground setting for
me to see somebody like you on screen
and so when I saw the Black Panther
universe um added in I was overwhelmed
how do you feel knowing that we as
people of color are receiving more and
more representation in this Marvel
Universe I I'm happy I'm super super
happy to be an American right now too to
be in the entertainment industry to be
considered a public figure and to also
be given the opportunities by by leaders
such as our studio heads when they when
they take on the task of broadening the
narrative for our stories it's it's um
it's plain and simple I think that as as
actors regardless of our race and our
gender we just want to be given an equal
opportunity to to be able to be
chameleons and continue growing and
connect with our audiences
so when directors and writers and
producers understand that change needs
to come from within and as public
figures we have the responsibility to
take the lead in broadening that
narrative
it just makes someone like me who would
be nothing but a positive recipient
super happy because I know what that
means for our future generations I have
three sons and nothing is making me
happier I keep saying happy but it's
true to know that they are going to
inherit an influx of like storytelling
through media that represents them and
makes them feel seen and heard and that
their lives and their their heritage
matters but but but only through their
merits so that I'm just really happy
about that
Benedict Cumberbatch and mr. Kumar watch
you can see in a few interviews that you
have read the screed but the Russo
brothers also say that no actor has read
the real final screed so I just want to
get to the bottom of that thank you so
much
I read a script whether I read the
script is for them to know and me to
find out when I see the movie tomorrow
but whatever script you read it's never
the film is it so it always changes and
these guys plus it every day sometimes
after the day sometimes will be probably
replacing this in December even after
the film is out they never stop at this
wheelhouse it's a busy place to work and
so whatever I read is not necessarily
what you're going to see so I could tell
you stuff about it but it wouldn't make
any difference
III knew it I don't know how I know it
chadwick boseman I knew it
hi Chadwick
I know we have to wait a long time for
Black Panther 2 but how much of Avengers
infinity war is at least black panther
1.5 it's not black panther 1.5 or black
panther 2 or anything like that I think
we have a strong presence within the
movie and it was it was great to to have
some of these people not gonna say who
exactly in Wakanda but it is his own
movie and it was great too to go from
what we did and with black panther and
bring some of that into into Avengers it
was it was a relief actually but it's
it's own thing
Anthony Anthony Russo Anthony Russo my
question is will we see Agent Coulson
come back for the Avengers all these
unanswerable questions we when we began
developing this movie you know we sat in
a room with Kevin Joe and I Markus and
McFeely the writers and we took we took
a we had a picture of every single
person who's who's been characterized by
a
and we hung it up on a wall all around
us and we we basically spent months and
months and months talking about where we
could go with each character how we
could draw them through this story
thinking about the very every every one
of these characters everybody on this
stage has been on a very specific
journey through the MCU that to arrive
at this moment and it was a very long
creative process that we went through
thinking about where we could take the
story where we could take the characters
how we can combine the characters in
interesting ways and it was about the
most fun creative exercise I think I've
ever been through in my life because it
was just us sitting in a room for months
and months telling each other stories
about these characters 99% of which
didn't make their way into the movie but
uh well I will say that that was our
process we thought about everybody in
the MCU we thought about how they could
play a role in the story moving forward
and starting tomorrow you will see the
movie who has a question for Elizabeth
Olsen I recently heard that you would
love it if Scala which got her own films
so what do you think Scarlet Witch could
bring to the table if she did have her
own solo film Paul and I joke a lot
about how much we would love to do like
a House of M spin-off and a really
domesticated indie version of it
and I think that would be a lot of fun
it's there that part of her stories the
reason why I love this character so much
and I mean I'm just happy that I'm still
included so I don't need a mic will you
just bring me back all of it this is
truly the greatest cast and we got to
work with the best crew and got to work
with the people who are the best at
their jobs and so there's nothing like
this experience anywhere else and we're
all very lucky to be here and enjoy each
other's company all the time thank you
danai I've heard rumors that some of the
women in the Marvel Universe have
pitched mr. Feige and all-female Marvel
movie what no I I know no details on on
that I was just thinking how excited I
am about brie Larson who's shooting
Captain Marvel right now how that's
gonna be a pretty awesome venture but I
mean the awesome thing that I think is
happening that we see happening across
many dimensions in in our entertainment
industry is we're seeing more women take
the helm in various realms and that is
not only about time but it'll make the
world a better place I think so I'm
looking forward to the future thank you
so much Avengers infinity war cast thank
you pres people is the best time I've
ever had in my whole life
thank you Robert Downey jr. thank you
Jeff amazing